let's bring in pentagon press secretary
john kirby
thanks for being here are you surprised
at how fast the taliban's been able to
make moves in afghanistan to take over
different sections of that country
brett we're certainly watching this with
with deep concern there's no question
that the security situation on the
ground is is deteriorating and you saw
that just over the course of the last
few days even more deterioration uh so
we're absolutely absolutely watching
this with uh with a measure of concern
no question about that administration is
describing this now more as an afghan
civil war
that they must essentially work out but
the intelligence community clearly is
saying that al qaeda has an intent
to take control into the taliban
if they take over the government
there isn't that why we went in in the
first place and are you worried you're
going to have to go back in
we're obviously concerned about any
resurgence of al qaeda or any other
terrorist network in afghanistan it's
not like they they all permanently left
we know that there are groups like isis
that are still operating inside
afghanistan and one of the reasons why
we are working hard to make sure we have
in place over the horizon
counter-terrorism capabilities to be
able to forestall any future threat
emanating from afghanistan to the
homeland but the other thing brad i
would tell you is that the the terrorism
threat out of afghanistan at least as it
regards to threats to our interests and
our and our allies and partners outside
and certainly at home is greatly reduced
from afghanistan that threat has largely
metastasized elsewhere in places like
northern africa and so we're mindful of
that and we're focused on that area as
well admiral you know 10 years ago u.s
forces left iraq with the same feeling
the same thought and then we were back
in in in some numbers to go after isis
because of the threat there i mean is
history repeating itself here no i don't
think so iraq and afghanistan are
completely two different uh scenarios in
two different countries two different
cultures uh and certainly two different
uh you know counterterrorism threats i
think i mean yes isis is operating in
afghanistan and they are certainly still
operating uh in iraq but it's a much
different group in both countries i
would tell you that
nobody feels like there's going to be a
need uh to revisit that history that's
why we are making sure we have in place
robust over the horizon counter
terrorism capabilities and those
capabilities are being used as we speak
bret i mean we are still supporting the
afghan forces in the field against
measures of the taliban but those same
kinds of capabilities will be in the
theater to make sure that we can't
suffer another terrorist attack from
afghanistan in the future why are those
over the horizon facilities and
opportunities not pulling troops out of
iraq and syria
well because we still have an isis
threat in iraq we're still there at the
invitation of the iraqi government there
is still obviously an isis uh threat
inside syria and they and and bret there
are over the horizon uh uh uh
counter-terrorism operations that are
occurring both in iraq and in syria as
well we have capabilities throughout the
region now look time and distance is a
factor here geography is obviously a
factor in afghanistan is a long way away
from some of these sources but we have
them at our fingertips and we can use
them there's not a scrap of earth as
you've heard the secretary say that we
can't hit
if we really need to
what's uh the point at which the embassy
in kabul has to close
well i wouldn't speak for the state
department what i would tell you is that
the president has been very clear that
we want to maintain a diplomatic
presence in afghanistan we believe it's
important to have that presence to
continue to further the kinds of
progress social political and economic
that we've been able to help foster
inside afghanistan key to that brett is
making sure that we have security at the
airport and what the department of
defense is focused on is making sure
that we're continuing this discussion
with the turks to have that security in
place admiral and you listen to the un
office of human rights talk about what's
happening on the ground already take a
listen
i think we should only have troops there
to make sure that it's impossible for
the taliban and for isis or al-qaeda to
re-establish a foothold there will also
hold the taliban accountable
to its commitments to keep al-qaeda or
any terrorist organization from using
afghanistan as a base for attacks
afghanistan
there are already reports of women
having been flogged and beaten in public
summary executions attacks against
current and former government officials
and their family members
military use and destruction of homes
schools and clinics and the laying of
large numbers of ieds improvised
explosive devices
that sounds horrible on the ground do
you
believe that's happening well we
certainly have no indications that there
aren't uh depredations being uh brought
against uh women and and other innocents
in afghanistan i mean that the taliban
continues to try to advance uh in the
country through brutality through
oppression through fear and as my count
my counterpart at the state department
said those kinds of tactics are not
going to lead to the level of legitimacy
that they say they want from the
international community that's why we
continue to do that i mean do you think
the taliban is going to say we're going
to we want to be legitimate in the
world's eyes that that's going to be the
threat that makes them stop beheading or
executing people bret they've said from
themselves that they want legitimacy and
that they want to have a hand in
governance which means they're going to
have to come to the table and be part of
a negotiated political settlement this
we we have long believed that there's
not going to be a military solution here
to the conflict inside afghanistan this
has got to be solved through through
politics through negotiation now
obviously they are advancing in a way
that would would argue that they're
they're not as interested in that as
they once said they were but this has
got to be an afghan land process and the
afghan military has the capability they
have the capacity they have the
advantage over the taliban and now is
the time for them to use all that for
some political and military leadership
and to put that into practice
we hear a lot about excuse me sorry to
interrupt we hear a lot about the afghan
military and i've been there many times
i've seen the training over the years
it just it doesn't seem to be a reality
the way we talk about it and the way it
deals with the threat on the ground
well again i can't speak for everything
that they're doing in every place in
afghanistan brett but they do have the
advantage and they and you know what
brett we are seeing them fight back in
some areas is it uniformly across the
country no but even as you and i speak
there are areas that they are contesting
and are trying to fight
the taliban but they've they've got to
be able to use the advantage that they
have we are supporting them from the air
where and when feasible but as our
capabilities in the country have
dwindled down so too of our abilities to
be able to be in a kinetic way uh you
know at a strategic level might much
effect it's we're having a tactical
effect but but clearly they've got an
air force that can do this and they've
got a they've got to use that that uh
the capability that we know they have
you and i have talked uh before and as i
told you i've been there probably 13
times since my time covering the
pentagon um when i went
the 10-year anniversary talking to then
general petraeus who was heading up
forces on the ground in 21 2011. i asked
this question i'm going to pose the same
one to you
for americans sitting at home on the
couch
why is this worth it
well that's an understandable question
especially obviously given the fiscal
challenges our country faces and i think
you then have to go back to 9 11 you
have to go back to why we are here in
the first place
and our core objective in afghanistan
needless to say is to ensure that the
country does not become a sanctuary once
again
for al-qaeda
so as we look at the map of the taliban
districts that have now fallen to the
taliban in afghanistan today the
question is why
was this worth it
i think it was worth it and look uh
brett uh i know you know people who have
fought and served in afghanistan i too
and like so many people here at the
pentagon you know i lost a friend over
there and i think uh one of the ways we
can say it was worth it was because
since 9 11 near 20 years now we haven't
been attacked uh from al qaeda we there
hasn't been a terrorist threat emanating
from afghanistan that has attacked our
homeland and that's quite a feat and in
the meantime we also made incredible
progress possible for the afghan people
more kids in school a higher life
expectancy a democratically elected
government there is a booming economy in
kabul or at least there there there
certainly had a growing economy uh in
kabul there has been progress made and
that progress is worth sustaining which
is why it's important for the afghans
together to to be serious about a
political settlement here
and for the afghan government to be a
critical player in that process but you
know back to your question why was it
worth it was worth it because we were
able to to make sure that we weren't
attacked from afghanistan again and the
president has been clear that we're
going to make sure we have the
capabilities in the region persistent so
that that can't happen ever again well
we'll see there's a lot of concern as
you know on capitol hill throughout the
country people who have fought there
and obviously all the blood and treasure
we as a country have spent there
hopefully you're right and hopefully the
taliban gets the message admiral kirby
thank you so much you bet brett
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else